this breakthrough may sound a bit like
science fiction for the first time
researchers have used an x-ray laser to
determine the structure of a protein
even as the laser blasts tiny crystals
of the stuff to bits that may sound like
a warm-up in some evil geniuses planned
to blow up the moon but it's really in
advance in the science of determining
the structures of proteins and a protein
structure pretty much determines what it
does biologists have determined the
structures of tens of thousands of
proteins using the intense x-rays that
emanate from circular particle
accelerators called synchrotrons but an
x-ray free electron laser which is an
x-ray laser that's driven with a
straight shot linear accelerator shines
a billion times brighter so we can study
crystals that are far too small to study
with a synchrotron in fact someday
researchers may even be able to
determine the structure of a protein by
zapping individual molecules with an
x-ray laser as a milestone toward that
goal the first protein structure from an
x-ray laser is one of our top 10
you